nouvelle retour au studio pour quelques
jours grosse actu beaucoup de
déplacements en ce moment et là ça fait
du bien d'entendre un peu dans les
locaux tranquillement enfin je vais vous
parler de samsung parce que j'ai une
info d'une source fiable très fiable qui
m'a effectivement donné des informations
très intéressantes sur ce que ferait a
priori samsung en 2020
[Musique]
cette année du lancement du samsung
galaxy folle smartphone pliable de
samsung j'imagine que ça vous aura
absolument pas échappé l année prochaine
samsung devrait faire quelque chose de
très intéressant du côté du galaxy folle
parce que je sais pas si vous allez fais
attention effectivement galaxie wade on
en a beaucoup parlé et je l'aï découvert
je les ai pris en main pendant une
demi-heure c'est un petit peu court mais
s'est trouvé vraiment intéressant pour
que le produit vraiment super
intéressant d'ailleurs ça fait des mois
que je vous en parlais que je vous dis
qu'ils attendaient avec impatience
l'arrivée des smartphones plia parce que
c'est une proposition qui pour moi est
une proposition d'avenir est vraiment
très intéressant et je pense que c'est
là dessus qu'on va aller davantage au
niveau des smartphones
et c'est vrai que ce samsung galaxy
folle c'est un des rares smartphones que
je n'ai pas eu envie de rendre lorsque
j'étais à la présentation pendant
laissez le moi je le trouve bien vains
très frustrant je trouve vraiment très
intéressant et ziad pour al tester
ultérieure non ça c'est l'ip est
justement justement samsung devrait
proposer en 2020 pas un nouveau galaxy
fold mais carrément une gamme des
galaxies folle plusieurs samsung galaxy
fold donc on imagine très clairement que
la gamme pourrait s'appeler ça paraît
assez logique
la gamme f alors ça ça n'a pas du tout
été confirmée mais ça me semble assez
logique vu l'appellation dé gamme par
samsung
la gamme a eu la gabegie mais ça s'est
fini la gamme est ce là on serait dans
la gamme f lagab pliable de samsung et
donc il y aurait plusieurs smartphones
très clairement en 2019 le smartphone
qui a été lancée le samsung galaxy
forgues a été là pour prendre un peu la
température pour voir ce que disaient
les gens pour avoir un retour le grand
lancement au niveau plus lire et mass
production
ça se fera en 2020 avec plusieurs
smartphones or ce qu'on peut très bien
imaginer c'est effectivement déjà
d'avoir des smartphones à plusieurs prix
ça me paraît assez logique là on est
quand même un peu plus de 2000 euros
c'est très cher ce parti pour tout le
monde on n'est pas non plus sur une
production énorme dès lors qu'ils ont
une plus grosse production mécaniquement
les prix vont chuter
mais ce qui pour eux c'est très
intéressant c'est imaginer différents
formats là aujourd'hui on a un format un
peu comme un grand livre avec un petit
écran sur le dessus un écran de 4 pouces
et qu'avec là on se retrouverait un peu
sensiblement sur le même type de format
mais on peut aussi imaginer comme un
smartphone à clapet tout simplement ça
c'est pure spéculation de ma part ça
pourrait paraître assez logique que
samsung pourrait expérimenter ou
travailler sur différents types de
formats en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que à mon avis la copie
être corrigée et améliorée et ce qui me
semble assez logique là dessus si vous
voulez c'est que samsung cherche à assis
priaient cette grande encoches que vous
avez héros du samsung galaxy fold à
l'intérieur elle peut sembler assez
disgracieuses même si effectivement il
ya eu un gros travail logiciels pour
bien intégrer ce que cherche à faire
samsung très clairement en 2020 c'est
tout simplement de se débarrasser de ces
petites bulles de ces petites encoches à
l'intérieur ses smartphones pour vous
proposer comme le font d'autres des très
grands écrans dépourvu d'encoches
dépourvu de capteurs en tout cas
apparents et a priori on n'irait pas sur
une caméra pop up en 2020 dont ce serait
la même chose sur le samsung galaxy
folle on se retrouverait sur une caméra
directement sous l'écran et je pense que
c'est là dessus que samsung va aller en
2020 sur sa gamme s mais également sur
sa gamme f
un grand écran une caméra cachée dessous
vous ne verriez quasiment pas vous
pourriez identifié lorsque vous sauriez
en mode appareil photo d'ailleurs ça
m'avait été confirmée par quelqu'un de
samsung ya quelques temps que
effectivement le galaxy folle ce n'était
pas juste un coup d'essai tiens on tente
le galaxy phone et si ça marche pas on
arrête non samsung a un plan qui est
prévu sion plusieurs années pour le
galaxy folle et donc la deuxième étape
du plan ça serait l'arrivée la gamme
folle je vous lis ça mais pas du tout
été dit par une personne de chez samsung
et par quelqu'un de très bien informé
c'est pas la peine de me demander en
commentaire en mai ça joue ce soir je ne
vais rien je suis une tombe je dirais
absolument rien je ne dévoile pas des
sources
et heureusement d'ailleurs ça craindrait
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ça c'est un
truc est vachement intéressant par
contre sans parler en commentaire est ce
que vous seriez potentiellement
intéressés par un smartphone pliable dès
lors que d'un point de vue financier
sent quand même beaucoup plus abordable
si on pouvait imaginer arriver sur
smartphone dans le prix de ce qu'on est
sur le haut de gamme d'une gamme s à
1200 euros
est ce que vous pourriez aller est ce
que ça pourrait vous tenter et qu'est-ce
que vous attendriez d'un smartphone
pliane garder sur le format livre on
actuellement sur le galaxy folle de 2019
ou alors pourquoi pas avoir un
smartphone à clapet ça pourrait aussi
être hyper intéressant d'un côté
miniaturisation parce que serein format
livre vous gardez pharma nos smartphones
un peu classique pour passer dans votre
poche ou dans un sac à main dans ce que
vous voulez mais en imaginant qu'on
passe sur un format clapet on prendrait
le format nos smartphones actuels avec
des écrans de 6,5 pouces voir un petit
peu plus et vous le plaignez ce qui fait
que vous auriez un espèce de truc de
quatre pistes est repoussée nuit dans
votre poche un peu plus large mais tout
petit ça ça pourrait être vraiment
intéressant et notamment de fond des
sacs à main qu'est ce que vous pensez de
ces deux formes al
pourrait le mieux vous convenir et
qu'est ce que vous pensez de vie d'avoir
une caméra cachée sous l'écran pas un
pop-up panne mécanique rien qui sort pas
un truc qui se retourne comme sur les
iphone 6 vraiment une caméras planquées
sous l'écran est ce que ça vous paraît
intéressant viable oui quoique comment
vous marquez tout semblant commentaires
on en parle ensemble d'autant plus que
vous avez vu récemment les problèmes que
huawei rencontre au niveau des états
unis avec le fait d'avoir été blacklisté
aux usa ça pourrait être compliqué
retardée peut-être en tout cas le
développement de la gamme pliable de
huawei ça prenait le champ libre un peu
plus à samsung pour lancer sa gamme folz
en 2020 dites moi ce que vous en pensez
on en reparle très bientôt et dès que
j'ai des infos un peu plus chaudes
croustillants comme ça partager avec
vous à bientôt ciao
[Musique]